e daje de paranormal activity oh mio dio
oh mio dio le mani al contrario permesso
non funziona qua o l'artrite le mani no
allora aprì la porta
porca vacca questa la torcia a doppia ma
aprendo scusa sì però allora se io ho le
mani monche ma se non uno un'ora ma qual
era il problema sarei presa
correttamente scomparirà dalla tua mano
sono jack nobile abracadabra alla casa a
figata ok ho capito fammi partire ci ha
finalmente new game ma che figata
incredibile normal doppio malto start
new game di we love e bright sì come al
solito dentro una foresta che non si sa
come ci siamo arrivati però sti cazzi
già il fatto che c'è una staccionata
vezza scassata non è che mi che sia il
massimo però vabbè benvenuti in
paranormal activity hanno finalmente
fatto il gioco di paranormal activity
che lo aspettava da una vita anche
perché ai tempi io mi ero terrorizzato
col primo paranormal activity quando
hanno deciso finalmente di fare
videogioco
cosa c'è scritto hamingway tour it on
the kills the national hiring sfotter ok
la chiave di nascosta dove la nascondono
gli americani la chiave dovete che tipo
di film americani nascondono le chiavi
fuori dove nascano sicuro qua dentro
sicuro no ecco lo sapevo mi chiara galli
in america saperi entrare in qualsiasi
casa esistente cioè le chiavi le
lasciano sempre fuori impossibile
sherlock holmes chi ha questa chiave si
doveva
un po più tetro al rumore di apertura
della porta grazie torcia non c'è torcia
c'è perfetto permesso devo andare a
piedi sopra vedi non fa scherzi che
faccio sparire pure te cos'è sta roba
bene cambiamo gioco inutile che mi
indichi di sopra tanto non ci vado di
software per luca zocco tre classi
l'invito meglio non riesco a farlo però
ci sono quasi madonna raga che
ambientazioni incredibile per un horror
in bouar sul problema nel
[Musica]
non vi faccio sparire tutti quanti è
così guardare no no sito stai si sia
aperto nessuno questa porta salve è
veramente il gioco e guardi eversivo che
abbia mai visto ci ha fatto da dio
sempre di essere tipi sta a casa c'è
libero giuro non me lo so spiegare un
abito rosso quello di litri story ciao
mazzo che brutto pupazzo mare che è
successo permesso
fatemi accendere qua c'è un'altra porta
come può esserci un bagno collegato da
due porte e allora innanzitutto sto
bagno o una chiave da una tua sorella
qualcuno nella vasca no grazie a dio
perché in genere negli horror pieno di
gente la basic uscire fila la chiave
maledetto sia per tavola portali che ben
si avverta doccia bene questo gioco sta
diventando molto più tragico di quanto
pensassi
anche perché l'atmosfera è bella pesante
però vabbè ma chicca per toste porto
scusate
tana tua sorella morta diceva pensa
aperta l'altra portano permesso vari j
qua sono entrato nella casa di qualcuno
ma per piacere lorenzo facciamo le
presentazioni dopo per carità è però da
bambina ma cos'hai cos'è libro ma perché
non riesco a parentele maledizione le
cose per terra
madonna che nervoso quando riesco a
prenderle 9 matera il sensore schifosa
di un mood gesù se devo fare questo
libro la bibbia la bibbia ho trovato una
chiave io prima ho trovato questa chiave
bambina
[Musica]
dove ha insegnato la lama che si mettono
a posto i mobili quando finisci di
giocare perché non riesco perché c'è il
tivano altri problemi nel giocare il
boara cosa mia
ed è nel libro possa aprire allora
aspetta che questa è la pagina di
chimica e chimica non l'ho mai capita il
metal alchemist tu lo hai fatto a
passare che c'ha armadio che è caduto
vabbè guatta frac e la cucina quella
agosto 2002 dove è la cucina in questo
posto non ci credo che se non dovevi
un'ora m
andiamo da un'altra parte la cucina dove
lavorava lo sgabello hanno un cane o una
2000 ma sta scherzando dai non prendete
la buona cha latina e facciamo un frank
prima che la apre e finisce nella merda
o il frigo santo gesù secondo me
dovreste
tra un pò meglio il cibo perché se lo
facciamo uscire così non è il massimo
pennywise perché mi metto a giocare sta
roba da potreste smettere con questa
canzone imparare mentis che finalmente
qualcuno ha messo la dubstep bambina
esattamente di quali disturbi mentali
sofri spiegano
[Musica]
basta parto io lo so perché ho visto
talmente tanti euro che li conosco i
cliché adesso io entro in questa stanza
e la canzone riparte lo so già lo so
bambina puoi smetterla dico ma mi prendi
per il culo no aspettate non ferma dove
vai ma perché non perché io sto giocando
sta roba madonna ma non migliorare
neanche più il personaggio adesso
cammina ma qualche cosa sta a casa ma
distanze ma mina o eccola da hai fatto
cascare tutti per amare una
registrazione
veramente ho trovato un accendino laga e
anche del buon whisky maledizione infami
fosse veramente utilizzare un veramente
che figata
si è un po molto che ci sia ma basta
correre basta
puoi stare ferma un secondo che almeno
andiamo in giro insieme possiamo
dall'altra parte della tube caduto a
mario che piange non mi interessa viene
impiantistiche passo tu non sei la
bambina vero tu non sei la bambina tu
non sei la bambina ma se la famiglia via
via deve di quadri capitoli
dentro dentro dentro la cina non ho né
filmati né veronesi non vedo parte
questo bisogno a maggio c'è crudo
prenderci di nocerino ok sono riuscito a
chiudermi nell'armadio ma per culo juan
margets va bene ma io proprio con
l'accendino
a parte farmi prendere gli spaventi ma
tu serbia qualcosa nella vita
basta cos'era hanno lanciato qualcosa
giusto
salve ragazzi da posto quanti
televisione la rete in casa giusto per
chiedere
e non me la faccio più questa domanda ma
se scassato pure l'accendino la cina
caso quello basta così devi non la roma
gigi e non vedono un vetro quando avete
tempo scegli il tuo fatto scegliere il
patto delle 18 passo passo di so perché
deve essere così buio
cos'è una scelta come quando devo
scegliere se andare alle superiori al
liceo
chissà che va dal liceo
non ci voglio finire prendi lo prende
porca vacca che questo provato vieni
vieni 0 viene perché adesso diventato un
libro prima aveva una battaglia alla
mannaia e la mia scelta ha il patto si
vede che ho scelto il patto della
mannaia saic e patatine c taglio con la
mannaia
vabbè balliamo vabbè balliamo non va
bene scassiamo aperta messo a distanze
just a casa ma lei ragazzi questo era il
primo episodio di paranormal activity
wired spero che vi sia piaciuto cioè
figo nel senso mi sono cagato addosso
però vedrete nel prossimo anche secondo
me un po peggio ve li siete ragazzi così
duramente piace anche qualche minuto una
descrizione centrali fischiate riuscì
vediamo anno prossimo video per ragazzi
[Musica]